[Music]
in 1966 Martin Luther King moved his
family into an apartment in the West
Side ghetto of Chicago he had become
increasingly more focused on economic
injustice and in 1967 he took the
initiative to start the Poor People's
Campaign the impetus behind the Poor
People's Campaign was to bring to the
attention of Anwar government that there
had to be a responsibility for the
condition of all people and that poor
people didn't have to be poor when we
had so much wealth in this country it
means that the civil rights movement
will have to place a great deal of
emphasis on grappling with this economic
problem we must identify absolutely with
the program to get rid of poverty and we
are going all-out to deal with this
problem of employment discrimination and
to try to build a climate in the nation
through political action so that there
will be fair employment as well as full
employment for all people dr. King was
the most visible spokesperson and leader
in the civil rights movement a situation
resulting in controversial exposure and
alarming threats we live every day under
a great deal of tension and under the
threat of death because they're still
those individuals who desperately oppose
us and what we're trying to do and
they're still the lunatic fringe and the
extreme writers who will do almost
anything to block our advance on April
3rd 1968 Martin Luther King attended a
march in Memphis where he later that
afternoon delivered a speech now known
as I've been to the mountaintop
we've got some difficult days ahead but
it really don't matter with me now
because I've been to the mountaintop and
I've seen the promised land the
following day on April 4th Martin Luther
King was shot standing on his hotel
balcony he was pronounced dead within an
hour all I all I can say is that it just
changed the course of human history
[Music]
we had our funeral to deal with there
were some who wanted to put a royal
coach and the staff would wear top hats
and spit tail coats and that debate
didn't last long
it's had no - the Kings last campaign
was support people's campaign and that's
what we should focus on that campaign
[Music]
for me the legacy of Martin Luther King
is that he symbolizes the continuing
effort to achieve a more just and more
humane nation I believe that the legacy
of dr. King is show real love and
concern for each other actually when he
was killed it was I don't think there
was anybody who didn't anticipate that
he was a shepherd for my people I would
say
who dared dare take on that role knowing
what it could lead to and still he
stayed on
[Music]